Thank You Tamsin for the intro so it's
often said that you are not your user as
smartphones find their way into the
hands of billions of users your
assumptions on how people will use your
apps will constantly be challenged on
one end of the spectrum you will find a
new generation of digital natives who
have no memory of a live pre smartphone
on the other hand you'll find older
digital immigrants that are only now
coming to terms with smartphones and the
possibilities that they unlock as we
think about how to build apps for the
shifting needs and behaviors of users
it's my pleasure to welcome our
distinguished panel who will share their
experiences in building products for
vastly different demographics so we're
joined today by John Neyland from bumble
which is a new way to meet data network
we have come out eager the co-founder of
a VCR the developer behind funny mate
video a video editor and creative
community and Virg an ahmadi who leads
products and is the founder of neuro
Nation a leading brain training program
so onto the first question do you feel
that there's a generational gap in users
expectations and behaviors on mobile and
or is it more of a sea change in
behavior that cuts across generations
Jon if you'd like to go first sure I
think it is well I'm gonna do that
annoying answer where it's both it is I
think it's affecting how everyone works
you've got new apps with new behaviors
the degree to which it's I guess
creating a true change and how you act
depends on how much of a lifetime of
past behaviors you have if you're in
your 40s or 50s you have you know half a
century of behaviors and experiences
you're grafting on to a new app new way
of meeting people whereas if you're
younger in my case I sort of you know
came into a jazz this was also coming in
to age or if you're another decade
younger than I am which is depressing it
is you know it's really all you've ever
known
and I've found I think the degree to
which it is changing is directly tied to
how much experience pre digital pre
mobile pre-social you have
so when it comes to our audience which
is quite young so kids and teens we can
see that they're really the pro users
and they're digital natives compared to
users close to my age for example they
can really use all the nitty-gritty
details of the tools we provide to them
so definitely when it comes to these
younger generations you can see that
they're much more mobile first and much
more digital native compared to the
older generation yeah so we talk now
about the older people though our app of
course has also younger ones but
regarding the old people you know we
have this aging population in general in
society and in Germany for example 20%
of the population of 65 years old or
older and you need to imagine that by
2030 every third German citizen will be
65 years old or older so the
demographics are changing a lot and
these guys are different than these
young hipsters that we have right now a
lot of times in the apps so with them
for example there there's two things
that I think are a lot different so one
thing is perception the other thing is
understanding computer interfaces so for
perception of course as you age your
ability to see things to perceive things
is not as strong anymore as it was when
you were young so that for example for
our app we once build a version of it
brain training app specifically for the
elderly and we do just in cooperation
with a company yet provided rent rest
houses rest homes so there we had to
take care of the visuals for example
some colors cannot be perceived as good
so you have to take care not only of
increasing font sizes but also changing
the assets of your app and that's that
some things that that we look at so it
sounds like everyone here should
definitely anticipate their aging
audience and think about how you can
prepare as well with your product so for
most of you you are not your target or
your target audience so how do you make
sure that you're building products that
really meet their user needs so maybe I
can start so for us we have a big beta
tester your user base and we have some
internal people closer to that
demographics and age that talks with
them almost every day so we get a lot of
feature requests from from our beta
testers and and the sometimes we bring
new features and they fine-tune and they
give us some insights that we don't
really knew beforehand and also we look
at how they use the existing features of
our app and we get ideas to make certain
parts more efficient or bring new
features based on what they actually do
so it's really the constant
communications very close communication
with these active Starr users of our
community great so how about you John
I think there's sorts of two parts of
the flow of information that you need to
look at and adjust to deal with people
who are in a very different demographic
than yourself the first is the distance
from you know the entire world up to my
ears and eyes and then the second bit of
distance which is so much smaller and
yet so much harder is the distance from
there to my brain and actually
understanding it and internalizing these
things in the first case I think bumble
is a fortunate well not portugalete hard
and they've succeeded in building up a
incredibly powerful network of young
people all around University campuses
and in other parts of life around that
age to encourage them to use the product
to get feedback from them and the
workforce and mumble itself is also
predominantly female and you know five
to ten years younger than I am and so
I'm fortunate that there's no shortage
of data coming in a long course with all
the wonderful analytics tools we get
from Google and
like to look at how they're using the
app but the second part though was the
seed change and realizing that you know
you are as the product manager you are
not building something for yourself you
are a servant of the company and its
customers and you truly have to listen
to these people who even if they are
younger than you they don't have all the
degrees that you do or the life
experience you do they have an
experience that is every bit as valid in
the case of this particular product more
valid and more important so I think
those two chunks are what you have to
deal with and focus on the most right
yeah what we look at in addition to of
course the data and what's interesting
to us is what our customer care teams
tells us so we their people call us and
then they have questions on the product
and in these cases you get this
qualitative feedback while you listen
how they talk and you want you see that
they for example the old people they
really don't understand the computer
interfaces this is not natural to them
for example you would listen to
something like you would ask them so
what is your browser how do you how do
you open up your website and then they
would say what is the browser so then
you would ask them okay how do you get
into the Internet and they would say
well with Google and they don't make
Chrome they mean the search engine so
they don't really get the concept of
death and also they don't get the
concept of an app store so this is what
we have right now of course they learn
but they didn't grow up with these
things so they take some time for them
to to get this in their head yeah so
taking into account what you've all just
said about how you're building for
people that are slightly different to
yourselves what impact does this have
one the way that you think about your
product roadmap in technologies that to
build in so one thing I didn't know
before I started the company is so how
much these young generation was creative
and how much they have these internal
creative engines that
is looking for ways to you know show to
the world so basically now we are all
doubling down on building these creative
tools so that they can the audience can
show off their creativity creativity so
using all these new hardware features
from house a lot from Google and really
trying to translate it to an easy-to-use
fashion for our audience I think in the
case of bumble it's forced me to really
evaluate assumptions that I wouldn't
even you know it would even occurred to
me that there's a different way of doing
things now I think one of the most
concrete examples I have is when we were
in the process of building bumble biz
which was released on Android today and
Germany go download it and play with it
a sort of business networking twist on
bumble to do more than just meet people
for dating we needed to sort of find a
way to importing your jobs in your work
history or education history into the
app and I think anyone you know age 29
or higher would just sort of
automatically think well obviously you
go to link did you know clear as day
it's like going to Google for search you
just do it or I guess in the case of
Germany you'd use sing sing that that
one but in the case of these people when
I went to share these plans with our my
younger colleagues I mean it wasn't so
bad that they said what's LinkedIn they
didn't know what LinkedIn was but that
was like something that old people use
and that was just so mind-boggling to me
because how could you not use a
networking thing how are you going to
find a job shrug Wow so we had to
reevaluate with the core how are we
gonna get you know given a limited time
to get this done how do we get this in
in the end we went with Facebook because
they're apparently just telling
everything to Facebook I think now in
another five years we're going to find
that the 18 years 18 year olds and five
years are gonna be you know not even on
Facebook and I will pull it from
snapchat or something yeah well for our
roadmap there's there's for example one
quite
interesting project on it for the
elderly
it's about digitalizing dementia
assessments and we do this in a
collaboration with the charity clinics
and german institute of artificial
intelligence the project is also funded
by the German Ministry of Education and
Research and this is a long-term project
as you can hear and for digitalising
dementia assessment we look at how it's
done right now in the clinics and there
the patient talks to the doctor the
doctor asks some things and based on
this the doctor calculates a score that
goes into dementia assessment so as you
can see this is a natural conversation
it's not a strange computer interface so
we hope a lot in natural language
processing so that we can replace this
kind of things with assistance that can
then lead the conversation with the
patient and assess this risk in dementia
and on top of that it will be even more
reliable because right now for some
tests in dementia assessment one out of
ten times the doctor calculates it wrong
yeah so that's quite important to do
this right and to offer the right
interface to the old people great and so
there's growing awareness that
technology has the power to do good and
also to do bad and so of course do you
feel that you have a real responsibility
towards being mindful of your users and
their overall well-being yeah so when it
comes to especially for kids and teens
we try to make the community as safe as
possible and you know suitable for their
age we have a lot of tools internally
that we use to moderate against for
example bullying something that I
learned also after I found that this
company was bullying was a big problem
in this demographics so we have both
community powered tools where people can
flag up certain comments or you know
certain profiles and we have internal
people looking at things for like adult
content was we thought was going to be a
big problem
we had all these tools to filter those
out but that didn't turn out to be as
big as a bullying problem so definitely
I mean people nowadays this is where
they spend most of their time right so
and then we see all these reports where
when they get a bad comment from a
person that they don't know they feel
down we get comments from their parents
that's now their kids are you know
crying or you know not feeling bad so
there is all these and they're not still
there yet there's a lot of things to
still to do but definitely I think as
app developers we have this
responsibility to protect our yeah have
a safe environment I absolutely think
that we as company's legal behind them
have a responsibility to be you know
custodians of our users time and
responsible for their quality of life
especially with the younger ones because
again they're just coming into digital
technology in life and anything we do is
gonna play a much stronger role in
determining how they go through life and
it would force a someone in their their
40s or thirties or 50s you know sort of
a great power great responsibility thing
and within that though I think it isn't
necessarily against yourself interest to
do so it's not just you know the right
thing to do I think it's also in most
cases the best thing to do for your
business you know if you pursue
pointless vanity metrics like the number
of minutes somebody spends in your app
then yeah you'd optimize to just try to
always distract them always get them at
the most vulnerable point and try to get
them in which might be great for that
metric but it's not great for them and
maybe it's not great for more important
metrics like how much they convert to
being a paid customer in the case of
bumble we know from the data there are
certain times of the day and of the week
what engagement is the most valuable
there are actual times of day when
people are more likely to be swiping
right it's definitely not Monday morning
and it's we build around that and I
think we found that even if you if you
optimize for
the highest-quality engagement as
opposed to just the most engagement
possible you'll have an experience that
is you know you know better for you and
your bottom line and also better for
them and the society that we all live in
yeah well I also think we're responsible
of course especially as coming from a
health company and so we should not give
users like should not help them build
unhealthy habits yeah of course we take
the time offer users but it should be
reasonable and right now of course the
incentive for us developers is to more
short term take the maximum amount of
time that we can and this can lead to
establishing unhealthy habits however if
really AI is going to reverse
revolutionize health and if there will
be massive amounts of data and user
tracking then what if the future AI
assistant actually will be able to
reveal unhealthy habits to users so
helping them to see where they are
actually maybe spending too much time if
this works out then of course we
developers will have more incentive to
help them build like an establish a
healthy relationship with us and not an
unhealthy one yeah and I fully agree I
think having that user centric approach
to design is not only good of course for
your users but even more so for your
bottom line as well and so what would be
your number one piece of advice to
developers on dealing with the
generational gap I mean I cannot talk
with all the generations and
demographics but I can only speak the
audience that I am very familiar with
which are these youngsters and they are
you know digital natives they can use
your product in ways that you cannot
maybe imagined or you haven't imagined
before you've released it so try to keep
it as flexible as possible and try to
get feedback very quickly they're very
eager to provide feedback and they feel
like engaged and they feel part of the
community so don't be scared to ask ask
their feedback can be engaged with the
the app they as what we found was
they're more than willing to help help
the developer especially if they like
the app and if they like the product so
yeah great what about you Joe as
succinctly as possible talk less and
listen more being less distinct I would
say it is important to when you do talk
start with questions and make them
open-ended questions I think they're you
know certain dynamics of you know age
and and status and gender that if you
start where the statement it can bias
what sorts of answers you're getting
from these people so I think it's very
important to when you are asking these
questions make them questions make them
open-ended and you'll be you know
surprised where they go and glad you
found out instead of developing it and
finding out the hard way yeah so what I
would suggest for the future is really
to start start just understanding the
demographical change start understanding
that these old people will come and
right now they're maybe at their desktop
with the laptops using web applications
but as as they grow more into mobile and
into whatever kind of technologies we
will have it makes sense kind of to
learn how they think and how they what
abilities they have and what kind of
interfaces for example natural language
processing we can offer them to enable
also older people to use our products
great so that's it for my questions so
now I'd like to hand over to the
audience to ask any questions as well
thank you
any questions guess we've solved
everything yeah okay so judging from the
fact that people who are 14 years old
are kinda still dunno who they gonna
become and three or in four years and
the same happens with people when there
are 70 they don't know we're gonna be in
the five years how do you compute like
customer lifetime value in these
circumstances so calculating customer
lifetime value for for like old people
this is both for young and for all I
guess it's just the general idea how do
you how do you deal with the uncertainty
in in that age group
you mean the uncertainty that there will
be alive or like their retirement fund
could go bust because of the bank and
people who are 14 years old they still
don't have any money right now but they
will have it later well I can just tell
about the older people that these are
the most loyal ones actually because
once they are your customers they
actually they are not interested in
exploring all the different options that
they can do it's also a cognitive
overload of course so also we know that
old people are a lot more sticking to
their commitments to their own common
commitments
Trust is a lot more important to them so
once they find that you are a
trustworthy partner you actually have
longer life term values with those then
the younger ones who just jump from one
app to the next that's what I can tell
you about the older ones for the young
ones I think the customer lifetime value
is a difficult thing to compute anyway
so I mean we basically use the same
techniques that everyone use so we don't
do anything specific for younger ones
but what Rajan mentioned about the
younger ones is quite true that they can
switch from different apps if they get
bored so what we do is try to keep it
fresh
we try to make weekly releases try to
bring new content all the time so so
that the younger ones they're always
thinking that the app is always fresh so
they don't switch that quickly
you